[Music]
from no French model please the muse
tonight the scene she draws is horrid
not polite she dips her pen in terror
will you shrink
shall foreign critics teach you how to
think have Shakespeare's magic dignified
the stage if timid laws had schooled the
insipid age had Hamlet's Spectre trod
the midnight round or Banquo's issue
been envisioned crowned free as your
country Britons be your scene be nature
now and now invention appearing be vice
alone corrected and restrained can
crimes be punished by a barbed enchained
shall the bold sensor back be sent to
school and told this is not nice that is
not rule the French no crimes of
magnitude admit they seldom start off
just to alarm the pit
the tragic greets with no other licence
wrote nor veiled the eye but plucked
away the mode whatever passion prompted
was their game not delicate
while chastisement was their aim
electron now a parent's blood demands
now Tara side stains the Thebans hands
and love incestuous knots his nuptial
bands such as our scene from real life
it rose tremendous picture of domestic
woes if terror shake you or soft pity
move if dreadful pangs or tape unbridled
love excuse the bar
who from your feeling draws all the
reward he aims at your
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when Volvo
silence these antique towers and vacant
courts dull the suspended soul till
expectation wears the cast of fear and
fear have ready to become devotion
mumbles a kind of mental orison I met a
peasant and inquired my way the churl
not rude of speech but like the tenant
of some night haunted ruin born an
aspect of horror warrant habitude nun
there said he are welcome but now and
then a pious Mass priest and the poor to
whom the countess dealer arms and
covenant that each revolving night they
beg of heaven the health of her son soul
and her own what precious memory her son
in exile she wastes on monks and beggars
his inheritance for his Souls health I
never knew a woman but loved our bodies
or our souls - well who inhabits here I
do be like this castle is not line three
like so but be to sit made this is no
home for revenues and Alex - away
without Charl
is this your Gallic hospitality my lady
on my life would not Dustin rudely chide
from her presence of the wilderness
reprobates down loose
maybe them Van Nostrand notes can
styling hair cloths that's those dainty
limbs can't style on reeking pavements
and cold marbled in meditation puffs the
live long nights father graybeard I
cried a mercy time was my lord the
counted knob on a prosperous gentleman
were he alive
we should not know these moping melon
killings heaven rest his soul my marvel
not my lady cherishes his remembrance
for he was comely to sight and wondrous
goodly built they say his son count
Edmund manly like him
what have I bring tidings of count
Edmund last night and from the bars of
our Lodge fire flitted a messenger I
knew no good would fall no no no he must
not yet alas I pretty
he must not here set foot does my
Master's still breathe this vital air
days he in France I would make a weary
pilgrimage to kiss his gracious hands -
his feet but say wine our bones air for
NAR burns land has vanished driven by a
ruthless mother us tis hard indeed but
spare his mother such virtue never dwelt
in female form but Sir
count Edmunds being not 16 a lusty with
his father's very image I come to the
point
her name was big
ah Beatrice and
roguish eyes she never look at me this
Beatrice
[Music]
my lady cards retired a while beyond the
use Balaton
[Music]
[Music]
t7 us at break more she hides he under a
B and prostrates a some monumental stone
seems more to wait for her doom than ask
to shove it levitate my lady's better
goodbye motto quick hide me hence shoots
that same meddling monk observe our
conference there were five work toward
larger long range I can't be there
[Music]
I sifter sifter I tell be brother this
woman was not casting human mold 10 such
would boil council would unbilled our
Roman Church in her devotion is real
she prays because she feels and feels
because a sinner
what has the secrets in this untold tale
that art cannot extract nor penance
cleanse loss of a husband 16 years in
joy and dead as many could not stand
such sorrows my mind has more than once
imputed blood to this incessant mourner
Beatrice the damsel for whose sake in
exile she holds her only son has never
since the night of his incontinence been
seen or heard of it is clear tis clear I
have often my discourse to murder she
knows it not her muscles hold their
place no southern Russia no faltering
lid I get some love the failure of the
sex and apt just cause of each attendant
crime all right brother there we master
all the grass do you air the count her
husband so adored and so vented one not
her fancy till the nuptial rites had
with the sting of pleasure taught her
passion then we return to won't have
secret act
I know not that name one unguarded
moment may disclose this mystic tale
then brother what a harvest or soon or
late a praying woman must become our
spoil her zeal may falter I nursed her a
new horrors former tenants to fancy
visions phantoms and report she mocks
their farm credulity but trust me
memory retains their colors but this is
masterly oh where I seated high as my
ambition I place this naked foot on neck
of monarchs art our humble fabric rose
with power by craft wear it with
ostentation gain to the holy see despair
domain and a crimson bonnet may reward
your spoils never leaven lives this
steady woman can now be pious with so
many virtues justice is interwoven in
her frame nor will she wrong with her
son she will not see she loves him not
yet his mistress of his fortunes usurped
from her own once she sets apart a
scanty portion only for her ward young
analyzer her wise to school this meeting
lead the Train of young ideas to a
fancied object a mental spouse this is
already done but Edmunds death were
hopes more solid first report him dead
but his letters intercepted greatly
thought lo where it comes out Patriots
leave me
hurl ass must guilt ground are very
virtues grow they on sin alone and not
on grace
well now born lived my fully sated soul
thought non unhappy for it did not think
well Nair to return no more dare I snap
the thread of life eternity has scope
enough to punish me
though I should borrow a few short hours
to sacrifice to charity I sought belated
happily I'm found who needs the Widow's
mite longer asks your aid your gracious
foresight still prevents occasion no
more of this good father
I suspect none of your Holy Order of
dissembling suspect not me of loving
flattery will give me birch the church
could seal your pardon but you scorn it
yours are pagan virtues as such I praise
them but it has such condemned father my
crimes are pagan why shakes my soul and
nightly terrors
it is from within I tremble death would
be Liberty what choice have I I have
lost my husband my own decree has
banished my own son last night I dreamt
your son was with the Blessed would
heaven he were do you then wish his
death should I not wish him blessed
madam I must not get ass like that you
do abused my patience it ILDA seems my
Holy function to give countenance by
lending ear to such pernicious tenets
I'm wrapped beyond my bearing your son
we know prophetic demon bear within our
respite conscience that has spoken
she's that voice has told me with my
son's birth not his mortality muster
my sole unjust uncharitable as your
words I pardon me forgive me for the
discretion did not die in my words what
peace is there for me in the neighboring
district that lives a holy man the
sanctity is marked with wondrous kills
and so to begin compels a holy man
inquire of him
good father wherefore what should I
inquire must I be taught of him that sin
is whoa must I learn that minute stamped
with crimes of past recall that joy is a
momentary and remorse eternal death
alone can certify whether when justices
for Jews expected mercy shall grant one
drop to slake my torment here father
break off you to your calling I to my
tears and mournful occupation
down not my friend hardships of war have
chased out of the bloom of comeliness
and stamped this space with harsher
lineaments that well may walk mock the
prying of mothers I'm a mother through
whose firm nerves tumultuous instincts
flood their gut to tell her this is your
son and not her love my lord suspect for
hatred hatred is distempered why should
she hate me for that my opening passion
swelling Archer prompted a congenial
necessary joy was that because no
Florian she herself was woman then a
sensual woman she might have pardoned
what she felt so wet forgive me Edmond
nor think that I preach you have often
told me that night the very night that
to your arms give pretty Beatrice as
melting beauties was the same night on
which your father died it is true
wouldst thou have turned thee from a
willing girl to sing a requiem to thy
father's soul I thought my mother busy
with her tears while I stole to Beatrice
his chamber how my mother became a prize
I know not but her heart grew estranged
a strain was a trick of a grafted sorrow
grief fatigues still must I doubt still
deemed some mystery beyond the widow's
pious artifice but to meet her hand his
bounteous as her heart is cold nar
Long's revenues are as fully mine as if
I held them by the strength of Chartres
why set them on the hazard then I am
weary Florian of such a vagrant life
befits it me sprung from a race of
Heroes nor bonds priests to lend my
casual arms approved valor to quarrels
nor my country's normal I bought it but
against the Turk a holy war so it was
deemed I smoked the turbine race
mattered it to me whether in Crescent or
cross prevailed
true my lord deadly feuds for obsolete
fences thy recruits my friend is just
but had I not caused a tender cause the
prompt of my return this school to my
claim and worn as one my love by winning
my respect
she cannot surely after such terrors
wounds by her command encountered after
sixteen exiled years spurn me when
kneeling thinkest out as possible I
would not think it but a host of priests
around her they good men are seldom
found to please the cause of pity you
shall be bettered that the Saint your
mother may by child sycophants and
Counting jugglers be hailed a new Teresa
pray be not seen here let's again to the
wars Oh Florian don't so was sick of
riot tis time to bid adieu to vagrant
pleasures and fix the wanderer love
domestic bliss yes your farriner young
Adam Lanza has sobered your inconstancy
tell me is she fruitful has to be
dislocated tis true
add Eliza is beauty's type renewed is
she kind colds the middle bars the
parker from me how gained you then
admittance this whole month while
waiting your arrival I'm haunted her
countenance part Oh
Florian you you know with that favorite
Maiden might reconcile my mother part I
hear voices that seemed protein they
cannot know me see
[Music]
children whose behalf raised these
little supplements their artless hands
to heaven you seem a stranger or you
flip at no sir night in narbonne spires
countess dwells within a lady most
disconsolate her Lord was snatched away
in lusty life's full Vantage but no
account made up no absolution hence his
reaping relic or his fought a doom a
goodly cross erected thither we proceed
to chart our holy dirge and offer due
intercession for his soul's repose I
knew his son Edmund we're so turns he in
the grave is Edmund dead say how he fell
at Budapest and not to his dishonour 16
facial years has noggins province
groaned beneath the hand of desolation
for what crimes we know not I feel your
country's woes I love that Revere his
father's ashes I will visit this ruined
monument and at our leisure could with
some conference with you this is well
where is your heart
a mile without the town hard by
synchronous nunnery there expect me I
must have Benedict
maybe the the storm abates his cameras
do not go for I saw the Lightning burst
on the monuments the shield in our bonds
arms shivered to splinters down with
hideous crash the cross gains humbling
then I fled Huck sure I heard a groan
wretches like me good Peter dread nurse
doses my soul's proper language behold
she comes a voluntary victim
[Music]
accessing mournful pretty gracious day
what words of these and any month less
hope you they would seem a magic
incantation last year's Eclipse fell out
because your maidens cross to gypsies
palm to know what was become of Beatrice
who knows but sudden malady took off the
damsel Beatrice might or might not have
Sepulcher within the castle wall
peaceful by equivocation has stained my
name with murderers our suspicion things
foreign rise and load me with their
blackness erroneous imputation must be
borne lest whilst on that raveling the
naughty whereby lender clue may vibrate
to my heart but who comes here
since it's not far off the time the
porter willed me to expect him here
Oh Edmund me by prosperous care which
will restore the to thy state and a thy
love for at Eliza stranger tip charms or
purpose guide thy steps to this lived
webbing pardon gentlelady if curious to
behold the pious nature in whom narwhals
plains of a I sought this castle me
stranger is affliction then so rare none
well here but men Anthony sorrow and
contrition pleasure has charms but so
has virtue to your coffee phrase young
knight who speaks a berth above the
vulgar lady to see our affair stranger I
need some and hence Bridgett's monastery
tomorrow night if you could spare some
moments from your pastime I would talk
with me in presence of the Abbess
so this as well my introduction made it
follows that I move her for her son
women often wear the mask of piety to
draw respect or hide the loss of it
while snuffing incense and devoutly
wanton the pagan goddess grows of
Christian Saint well Edmonton what so
air thy mother bee I'll put her virtue
or hypocrisy to the severus of tests
countess
expect me
[Music]
[Music]
destroyed well what of that where every
Thunderbolt addressed to me no one would
miss wheet me
we know that do we merit five five I
blush to recollect my weakness my Edmund
may be dead my ad ELISA may taste the
cup of woe that I have drugged
what wretch could be a blacker criminal
than I am
what [ __ ] placed around me and the
fatal torch applied would it teach the
world unheard of sins
how dare I be esteemed be known I crimes
my Edmund has not a mother's hand
afflicted him enough madam young
paralyzer and treats to speak with you
the lady abbess tippin's to death admit
her now my soul recalled I come oops
I mean speaks can I hear these praise
has not followed blushes of my feet
recall my words that Eliza merits no in
chromium I am NOT innocent the dearest
orphan to my cousin who come purity like
buying abrasive soaps with fancy gifts
in vain to cheer me I am most unworthy
other discourse than diamonds charmed my
dear nor dare I now presume to call the
mother
my lovely innocence restrain my tears i
secret never why beats and throbs my
little heart with unaccustomed to month
impossible
thou hast conversed with a young
anonymous pent in her chambers
has detained our Abbas from the parlor
there I saw him off as he came alone we
talked of love he did she's well tis the
stranger I beheld this morning he
sorrows for a father something to he
uttered of a large inheritance that
should be his dust thou loved this
stranger yes
with such a love as I feel for thee his
earnest words sounds like precepts of a
tender parent and next to thee I think I
could obey him become my lovely orphan
harsh thy fears heaven knows how fondly
and subtly I love thee strangers not to
play my several tasks in and see if he
deserves thee now required nor slack
buys you due to the expiring Saint
[Music]
[Music]
the do of Grace rest on this dwelling
thanks my ghostly friend well either
stick in your sad eye I spell affliction
signature to tutor my an apt until the
school mate you come then with doctrines
and authority if all can medicate a soul
unsound as mine you mock my friendship
and miss call my zeal learn the measure
of their woes learn if the mothers
fortitude can brave the boat the woman's
arrogance defied the mother said so yes
imperious Dame on Buddha's plane by
slaughtered Edmund lies an unbelievers
weapon cleft his heart in the grave now
says my Edmund sleeps
how did some earn his fate priests mock
me not that you loved him loved him
oh nature bleeding at my heart yes
though this loved him hah
I am dying mistress yet nor would I
Brook insolent reproof produced by
warrant
assure my Edmund snake or dread is
vengeance my warrant is at hat this
gentleman beheld by Edmund breathless on
the ground is my husband look up
whatever dear behold thy son it is my
Edmonds voice dumb still I have killed
her my brain grows hot my lord was
straining your passion
see she revives art thou or not a mother
who we're never why did you hold me was
it not I no bone last she raves quick
answer comes of now understand live how
to behold your son he kneels for parlor
distraction what means this complicated
seen Horrors after my husband weakened
from our hopes told my soul Oh what is
this devious former bow my dad or my
living son I am thy living Edmund let
these scalding tears attest the
existence of by suffering son catch me
not how in that cruel breast revived
then all sensations except affection but
now my eyes I see my father at least for
that resemblance sake embrace Makarova
horror blast it be thy child lady I
doubt not your blessing first obtained
and gracious pardon he will obey your
pleasure and return to stranger climes
tis false
I will not hence am I not nor bomb
Springs cool banishment hear me thou art
my son and but I am nice sovereign to
this state is mine Benedict attend me
tomorrow
Edmund shut down learn my pleasure why
this is Majesty commanding sex strength
courage all our boasted attribute seems
of borrowed ray when virtue danes to
speak with female organs yes oh my
mother I will learn
tobei make but the blooming analyse of
mine and bare of me unquestioned
Narbonne sceptre to life's expiring lamp
resumes its wasted oil no more
I know thy spirit well but till this
hour I had not seen by passions Boyle or
the bounds of brutal mistake me not good
brother I would not know one half that I
suspect to I have acted as if not
suspecting tis time enough to make up
our account when we confess and kneel
for absolution still does my genius or
above a mankind how many fathers of our
Holy Church in Benedict I've you know
flattery brother
tis true the church owes Benedict some
thanks for her I forgot I am a man
enemies to Rome are Benedict's foes
interest bids us crush this cockatrice
and her egg already to those vagrants
she inclines as if the rogues that
preach reform to others like idiots
minded to reform themselves the cautious
brother you may lose the lady she is
already lost I cannot do and therefore
must destroy them how may this be
accomplished ask me not I guess her
fatal secrets I'd rule
that's it tremble if we fail peace
doctor peace nor when the lamb is nigh
must eels wrangle why sighs that gentle
bosom Oh Holy Father the pious Alice is
at peace we go to bury parting blessing
to the captain it must not be my be she
wills you restrain your steps within the
cloisters pale nor grant access but to
one stranger Knight the countess
commands
I don't leave that I charge the guard I
convent wherefore then this is Deepika
madam I was urging the fitness of your
orders I am the thing you made me crush
me spurn me I will not murmur should you
bid me die I know to remain in kindness
pithy tie my own detected life but
lingers around thee my child retire I am
much dispersed be patient lady this fair
domain now notes acknowledges the
sovereignty of the church I read a son
dares not attempt in the peace there is
no question of Lord Edmond leave us I
have to talk with her alone now
trembling voice is supernatural and
forfeit the spoils that tempest throws
into our lap
as Eliza
some on all my courage retrace my
precepts past nor let us here prevail
and moment that's worth of martyrdom the
burden male shall guard my spotless
hours assure my peace and thanked me for
hero it cannot be - na bong llama spit a
last a dear and with the stranger
Knights depart a bride unhappy me - sure
I have overburdened by charity if that
would drive me from hence restrain thy
arms dear lady ad Eliza thou words now
snakin now augment my fever hear my last
breath avoid the scorpion pleasure death
lurks beneath the pelvic of his lips our
retrospect of horror to the old I hate
that Eliza bow thou wilt be a wretched
does that do me to eternal sorrows have
deceived me on how she melts me what
have I said Oh lovely innocence how
about my only thought who was I born the
child of sin and I do not embrace thee
yet curse the hour that stamped thee
with a being alas was I born a child of
sin who were my parents I would pray for
them let's come let it strike me here
crazy from the earth what is my heart
well down yet cherish kind of start out
the conflict of the soul Otis the shield
me from this world and so sorrows Thomas
please must wait must never you the
towers of Narbonne warmest never know
that do
but by side patroness flying em I raged
forget distinction nature and make a
medley of unheard-of crimes
my aunt be too late plus she raised a
call for help
that pang Greek god was my last
sacrifice recollect thyself my soul
consummate the powerful para with
tremendous coolness to spit that reason
punished passions crime or reason ha ha
tis one of my convulsions down my sink
lost in eternal torment she is not here
shall we not follow her the most turned
out her Transport is fictitious I
tremble for her my cloud art young I
know this countess and heretic she stops
the church today as a numbered and thou
shalt do wisely to quit her she bids me
go
she pits me when the stranger night that
would me in our parlor and thou shalt
take her at her word myself will join
your hands and lo in happy hour who
comes to me go home in tears that cowl
shall not protect the injurious hung the
dare insult by innocence my gracious
lord yourself and virgin coitus must be
chin unriddle priest my soul is too
impatient to wait then pertinence of
flowery dialect does thou consent it
must not be thou shalt not when a beggar
this orphan this abandoned wanderer
taunted with poverty with with shameful
origin lovely add Eliza placed in your
arms can never feel affliction this the
good countess knows by my sire soul I
will not think her as she dared swarthy
that beauteous excellence in her very
presence I will espouse they like heaven
all sauce should they meet now great be
advised heaven knows how dear I tend to
your felicity the chapel is a few paces
hence arrived there I will speedily for
now
a few solemn words well be it so my fair
one this holy man advises well yes
heaven to be I fly Lord my only refuge
the business is dispatched
joined the purely moppet struggled with
her wishes invoked each sent to witness
her refusal nor heeded though I swore
their golden hearts were tuned to greet
her final hours the impetuous count
would form run the rights the maid
affrighted at such tumultuous
unaccustomed unsent
sunk lifeless on the pavement thus am i
revenged proud dame of knob on low a
barefoot monk the spays thy scorn
thus vindicates his altars whoa good
father
hasty in and speak sweet words of
comfort to our mistress her brain is
much disturbed good man Exorcist
thy Kings are a billion her sins press
her guilt has unhinged her reason she
raves upon her son and thinks he came
envisioned was no vision he has spoken
with her good too we could not be I tell
me it by quantum masters son has seen
his mom no joyous sounds where is my
lord
yeah and under these sixteen years has
my friend Edmond pined in banishment
while NASA's mum Eames goblins and
processions usurped his heritage and
made of Nar bone a theater of holy
interludes and sainted frogs but a darts
on these spells the enlightened day
issues that vile decease and truth shall
do mankind and Edmund
justice Benedict thou art a priest our
nation should be only quick do thy work
to the wound it is the consequence stand
off
thou art an accomplice madam it was your
warnings gracious pleasure that I should
attend you you forgotten me memory is
puma head destructors mine can hold only
two objects guilt and eternity he is
returned your son have you not seen him
would I had never this villainous monk
has set betwixt you and nature and
misreported of the noblest gentleman
that treads on Christian ground are you
a mother he says this was the demon
prompted it Hans he beckons me I will
not lies my lord wounded in the pot I
tear my hand
babies lose my strength my reason fail
darkness surrounds me let me die here
too much for art no tis fictitious all
twas I inspired the horrors she has been
so kind to utter at my suggestion art
war woman now subtle emblem of thy sex
composed of madness and deceit but since
thy reign has lost its poise
I will send those shall shake it beyond
the recovery of its reeling Gaius
this interval is well just my last boon
tremendous Providence and I will use it
as will the elixir of descending mercy a
woman's words and mothers whoa but honor
if I defy God is by profession a
soldier's onerous is a virtue a soldier
and his honor exists together and
together perish no suffer the ebbing
moments more inquiry atomizer my orphans
shall be thine need stop your loves are
known to me
I love idolize them lady recall by
wandering mind another licentiousness
holiday have been my school day me not
so reprobate my morals and my I would
not distance between the harlots gaze
and my friends were hide by my friend
what friend Lord Edmund what of him is
analyzes Lord her wet and bridegroom
confusion URIs monstrous tail her
prodigy of ruin does my own son boy with
beer sapphires and scorched his mother's
man
what means his a Vanitas now not grandpa
made it to his wishes
did I not couple distinctions horrible
Nana natural rights to grace my funeral
pile and meet the purest amazement will
hasten gravity powers my speed be not
too late
[Music]
[Applause]
do you hear it look on us and bless us
as your children
my children horah horah yes we are my
children
Eggman loose that hand there's no poison
tip poison to my soul hell has no venom
like a child star Chow agonizing the
thought who made this marriage who's on
hallowed breath pronounce Li sounds good
yes so devoted victim let thy blood
curdle to stone petitions circumventing
oh where this monster stands thy mother
mistress mother of my daughter sister
white the pillar of accumulated horrors
here and tremble yes I do triple though
thy words are frenzied so black must be
the passions that inspired Edmund I have
burst the boat of every type when Tao
shall know the fullness of my crime to
which this period in both my youth it
will seem piety declares me Edmund Oh in
pious night it's not that My Lord he
sleeps the curtains of the natural couch
and starts a find a thumb there Krish
have incredibly shocking images be
raving composed benediction discharge
elbows for a short interval give me
reason heaven it must be known the
fullness of my crime you know how fondly
my luxurious fancy doted upon my Lord
for a
in months an embassy detained him from
my bed a harbinger announced his near
return love dressed his image to my
dolly thoughts in its warmest colors but
the more in which impatience through
almost a sickness presenting with a
bloody corpse before me I'm raved the
storm of disappointed passion severed
all my reason assemble my blood were
there too warmly pressed oh too
officious to turn the tide of grief
aside Beatrice that attended me disclose
thy suit unhappy boy what is to come
shield me graces powers from my own boss
my fancy so the like swallowing a curse
in sound nor dare to say grief
disappointment opportunity raise such a
tumult of my mighty flood I took [ __ ]
his place Adams why are my arms 20 like
thinking around another tremble she is
my daughter flew to that monstrous night
burn old woman my dagger must retain a
tale like this no I must not strike I
dare not punish what you dare commit
dagger Maya will not recoil
Edmund - OH
peace and concealed of shaking quick
brave son legend
accident mercy who did this deed nice
what was the cause
follow me - yawning gulf man thou shalt
know I answer not a man you think me
lady thought eggs a piece o Edmund could
a blessing break from my lips and not
become a curse I would pour at Eliza tis
accomplished my lord
explain these horrors where I found your
mother if I face your wife wife thou
daring priest I have no wife thou dost
it now they must be a deep no rock my
tongue hear the dread sound escaping
bear away that hateful monk who was the
process now flooring we must taste to
where fell warm us war assumes its
ugliest form
I learned to rush on death ok I'm their
friend I must not finally Thank You Lucy
huh just my father calls I cannot see
him propose my lord we're all your
friends let us comfort your no
forbidding all the heat powers Gloria
bear bear her to the holy sisters saved
was my mother's will she take the veil I
never must behold her Nevermore review
this fear of monstrous guilt
no to the embattled foe I will present
this hated warm welcome be the savior
that leaves no hassle of adopted peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you know in public or in private
double entendre is my stripper to drive
at your news is sir are not more free
from ill on Mount Parnassus or on
Strawberry Hill and though with her
repentance you may hum one I would not
play your countess to become one so very
guilty and so very good an angel with
such Aaron's flesh and blood
such sinning praying preaching I'll be
pissed if I don't think she was a
Methodist 6-under produce of a vicious
age crimes must abound air secretaries
can reach his mask no canteen confessor
can assumes with acting zeal no flaming
bigot fumes till the rich harvest nods
with the swelling grain and the sharp
sickle can assure his game but soon
shall hypocrites their sight deplore nor
grim enthusiasts vast Britannia more
virtue shall guard her daughter's from
their arts shine in their eyes and
blossom in their hearts they need no
lectures and fantastic tone their lesson
lives before them on the throne
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I have the honor to introduce you our
fabulous cast Georgina Locke as the
Countess of Pylos Guanche a as Edmund as
Florian
Chelsea Phillips as analyzer
Charlie Gillespie as Benedict
Justin crisp as friar Martin
[Applause]
well Townsend as Pierre the porter
Stephen Clark as the service and Dale
war I'm Dick Dale David waro as odd who
as a bridge to our text and well also
jill campbell who is read art for what
and finally
[Applause]
bring out some chairs so please stay for
that and some of our afters blooming to
go hang up these very hot clothes but
they will come back in for the
discussion we're planning on maybe 20
minutes in here and then we'd like you
to join us at a reception after yes I'm
Katherine she iam the the resident
domitor VL rep and I'm the chair of the
department of dramaturgy in dramatic
criticism at the Yale School of Drama
and an 18th century British enthusiast
I'm delighted to welcome you here to
talk back I I want to share with you
I'll ask a couple of questions and then
and I'll throw it open to you just so
that because we're recording it there
are standards by with microphones and so
when when you're called upon if you
would just contain Your Enthusiasm until
the microphone can get to you that'd be
great I wanted to reduce a little bit
from Horace Walpole's PostScript to that
1791 Edition which is about 23 years
after the play was originally written
from the time that I first undertook the
foregoing scenes
I never flattered myself that they would
be proper to appear on the stage the
subjects so horrid that I thought it
would shock rather than give
satisfaction to the audience still I
found it so truly tragic in the
essential springs of terror and pity
that I could not resist the impulse of
adapting it to the scene though it could
never be practicable to produce it there
I saw to see see how wrong we can be 300
years later I saw to that
that it would admit a great situation of
lofty characters and of those sudden and
unforeseen strokes which have often
singular effect in operating a
revolution in the passions and an
interesting spectator it was capable of
furnishing not only a contrast of
characters but a contrast of virtue and
vice in the same character sitting and
by laying the scene in what agent
I pleased Catholic friends pictures of
ancient manners might be drawn and many
allusions to historic events introduced
to bring the action nearer the
imagination of the spectator the moral
resulting from the calamities attended
on unbounded passions of the moral of
the story even to the destruction of the
criminals race was obviously suited to
the purpose and object of tragedy so I
thought that would be a good place for
us to start since we have some scholars
up here I wanted to ask is the
mysterious mother a tragedy what is the
place purpose and object would you say
and I'll be happy to throw it out to
anybody who would like to answer well I
think there's there's a kind of textual
fault line in the play whether when we
conceptualize it as a tragedy on the one
hand he mentions our sealian categories
of pity and terror and hacking back to
an Aristotelian understanding a tragedy
in the PostScript that you've just read
but on the other hand as the prologue to
peace makes clear he is trying to
differentiate himself from classicism
and indeed French neoclassicism of the
18th century which subscribes to our
city near models of tragedy and in facts
holds Shakespeare responsible for
deviating from those and seeing him as
kind of gothic and barbaric and uncouth
and uncivilized because he doesn't
conforms notions of tragedies so I think
the plays relationship to tragedy is
complex on the one hand citing pity and
terror as the wellspring Aristotelian
cadby's but on the other hand
differentiating himself certainly from
conceptualizations of tragedy therefore
shakespeare sensing as the kind of guide
and the model to a tragic man and the
play is replete with references to my
beth to Hamlet's in particular I think
those his the models to which he turns
bearing in mind that for the
eighteenth-century Shakespeare is the
Gothic Bart gothic in in a very
different sense yes so essentially an
Englishman want to let us know that the
French got it wrong yes right what will
actually courted comparisons to
Shakespeare as his literary as his
literary target of aspiration is Jill as
Jill read in the prologue and here he's
taking that old Shakespearean chestnut
the bed trick and he's inverted it's
right as the seat of disaster rather
than the way to the comic resolution as
it isn't all as well and someone less
merrily in measure for measure what's it
I mean maybe you could talk a little bit
about describing the bed tricking and
Georgiana and and what what kind of
emotions that you go through while
you're while you're imagining that old
chestnut well I don't have a son you
know I kind of like the lines where
she's moving between loving and what she
sees as a son and at the same time being
disgusted but loving husband and being
disgusted by his son was quite an
interesting position to be in and I
suppose that it's I mean I can't really
think of anything worse to do apart from
murder you know so I'm in a very
difficult place really and I also think
it's slightly weird to sleep with
somebody the night that somebody dies
anyway but
so I I did find it quite difficult to to
get in to her from the inside but then
when I read the script and the more I
kind of read the language of the script
and the things about guilt and innocence
and the kind of the rhetoric that she
uses it helped me to to kind of use her
scripts if its kind of portray what
she's going through then sometimes we
start to feel it and actually where I
what I use to try to get closer to it I
mean I we talked about the spine and we
whiskey kind of you know keeping the
spine very straight and then bending the
idea of being disgusted by yourself your
stomach starts to kind of shrink and
once it's kind of vomited by the idea of
what you've done and that actually that
kind of physical clue helped me with
with getting getting closer to survive
mmm well that's gorgeous in its it yeah
but this also sort of touches on you
know many new moments of nervous
laughter as you might imagine and we
only got together on Monday night for
the first time so but we sort of had to
speed through the process and in
thinking about those sort of the the
horath a bad trip we're also back to
your first question in the way couple
you know is this a tragedy
the over-the-topness of it which is also
something that especially for those
scholars in the room to teach or tonto
them to undergraduates you know it is
this funny when the helmet falls right
and crushes the Sun there's something
something absurd around the corner so we
did we are preparing a musical version
tap dancing
yeah what was said that he never
flattered himself that the play would be
proper to appear on the stage and
setting aside the unlikelihood that he
never flooded himself did you find the
place stage worthy for today's lush
depraved audience and how did you make
how did you make it but how did you go
about making it stage worthy maybe you
guys could tell me the thing that I did
of course it you because it starts out
as a fiber Shakespearean play there's
been no Shakespearean shape and so I
realized that you know you wouldn't want
to stay around but two hours or
something like that so we need to get it
down so I happy so I had to cut it and
the ID which is brutal but then I found
but the performance after Walpole's
death where it been performers three
acts so I knew it was safe it could be
cut and I guess I thought probably
should become no as well so so that's
right then so I threw out things really
so what you're really doing is trying to
end with the final scene so it's a bit
like landing an aircraft I think there's
a landing strip which is the final you
know the final scene with the countess
and you have to throw out all the
luggage in the drinks trolley in order
to be able to reach that and so but an
interesting thing began to happen as I
work through it which is that once you
throw out all the positives and you
accent all the negatives like the
reverse of the song you know the what
you get then is this kind of melon drawn
dramatic line which seems to go through
it so you know so if you like it's kind
of ideologies rated on this line of
melon
actually interaction with which I hope
that this cutting is kind of done really
so and it's interesting that it's there
at all so you because you can see Horace
kind of making melodrama out of you know
as a as a kind of again a spine going
through it even though the plays
probably about other things you know
profound things about gills and you know
with religion and all those things but
that the line seems to go all the way
through it as I kind of work through it
in short today yes and in our early
conversations when you mentioned
melodrama
and we have a wonderful lighting design
candidate at my home University house
Trent and she she did these these
graphics for us and so that got me
thinking not just about melodrama as the
over-the-topness but also might music do
some work and to supply what had to be
caught here and a lot of what had to be
connected Charlie and and Justin are
back is the religious struggle that that
Walpole is staging here you know
imagining this this early Reformation
are almost pre-reformation moment and
coming back and so all of these zingers
about an enlightened age and reason are
also in the context of a very
fascinating and if anti anti-clericalism
that it is also under fascination you
know with with all things Catholic and
with a kind of three
in past so we were just you know looking
for ways to give that feel even though
there's debates in the play and there's
those lines which are very interesting
might not be the most playable to get
back to the notion of disgust maybe
picked up as I think is this hugely
important and interesting in this play
is to look at how that term for Walpole
certainly in the context of this play is
inseparable from a perception of female
sexuality and what seems to happen in
the correspondence around the play that
he undertakes particularly with his
friend Mason is a concern with disgust
and it's quite clear that disgust
pertains to the fact that this is a
woman who has not unconsciously
committed a tragic error but someone who
desires who is desiring and he was a
kind of sexual agent and who chooses
voluntarily and consciously
her son as a bed partner and it is that
element of disgust that Mason suggests
he rewrites out of the play and turn it
into an unconscious tragic mistake but
it's quite clear that that the issue
around disgust pertains to walk for
welcome to a consciously deliberately
desiring women which I warrant were
technically has difficulties in
socializing is of course many of the
late 18th century do that women can't be
trusted as well as special
essentially powerful you know there's
there's also a history of sexuality it's
only at around this time that women are
being given a sexuality of their own
anyway and not seen simply as inverted
desiring bodies design bodies that have
sort of organs and desires of us of the
inverted versions of the masculine the
two sexes model of desiring arises in
the late 18th century where women are
and have bestowed with their own
sexuality and that is I think in almost
be threatening for someone right and
these are words that Edmund uses he
calls his mother a sensual woman and it
reversed two organs yes such a play has
never done until there the bodies of the
women are strewn on the stage and then
supremely sorry I think we should I
think I think should open up the for
questions from the audience if there if
there are any I mean I have some more
but I don't want to usurp your your
curiosity and we do have the remainder
of the cast beckons yeah they could take
questions too as well no yes right here
well yes I was quite intrigued by this
issue of female sexuality and must on
which the whole clock turns obviously
and if this treated in other literary
works at the time or is it treated I
don't know
and pulpit is it treated in
philosophical writings at the time I
made forgive me and I don't know much
about it but it just you can see in
Gertrude - I mean it didn't have life
you know just talk about having youth
that kind of the deep suspicion of a
woman particularly a woman of a certain
age who continues to desire you've been
through the restoration with people like
you know mrs. Lovett in man of mode and
this kind of you know that the older
woman's sexuality is is almost like it's
like a like a death bit for for male
senior I mean and it's seen as a kind of
problem yeah I think that starts at the
reduced on stage of experience danger
but in Indy age as well sometime in the
1780s there's a play called the
mysterious husband and that's about
incest as well but it's not quite the
same way and the storyline in that is
that yeah the father has a mr. of the
English father has a mistress in Paris
and then his adult son who is estranged
from the father goes to Paris and he
takes it with the mistress unbeknownst
to each other so so there's a kind of
you know I guess in in that period you
know they're exploring the limits of
incest so London audiences you know kind
of comfortable with thinking about that
I think you know and all perhaps that
exploring I mean you know they're
probably other incest place although
18th centuries I don't know but
this notion of the kind of dangerously
desiring woman would become a staple of
gothic fiction in the late 18th century
and almost invariably to catastrophic
dramatic enemies one thing from a
directive writes which shall de coeur
and beyond these images of passion the
work that they become associated with
his passion which has been sentimental
over time with also sexual imagery and
just thinking specifically about the
stage I mean it's at the restoration
that we have women in women's parks for
the first time in English theatre and
restoration comedies those those
comedies between 1616 and about 1700 are
known for being especially sexually
frank dirty there's lots of adults
really there's lots of sleeping around
and that sort of all comes on and a
burst after charles ii reopens the
theaters now that the Puritans have
closed them
so there's a kind of cultural revenge
plot on the Puritans that's going on
right yay Puritans are gone we can have
sexy comedies now but also women's
bodies on the stage and then you know
that that that peak dies down but we
still have some of those types that are
our part of again discovering where the
stage does or in women or embodying
women but what is interesting too is
taking the bed trick from that falls in
tradition that comic bawdy tradition of
the sibling in which lead and then
repurposing
to try to carry yeah and I think too
that you if you think about the you know
the theater in London was was a
commercial idea and the people who began
to have money were of course than the
merchant class from the merchant class
want to see themselves on stage and then
they aspired to the toys of the
aristocracy but with the morals of the
of the birds was Ian and so you get
fetishization and I think the comedy
goes a long way toward the conscious and
we're Charlie let's be down there I
would make him answer but you know yeah
I think that that's an important
distinction
whatever discussed is particularly local
and his you know his possible sexuality
and his disgust at the idea of woman
and the the religious debate that's
playing out here but I think they
intercepted Benedict you know the you
know for karela I have forgot I am the
man right you know and I've kind of an
outsider Ness to heterosexuality but I
think the difference is that in relation
to Catholicism Walpole can never safely
adopt an unequivocal attitude had
discussed in the way that he can in
relation to to femininity it's it's much
more ambivalent in relation to
Catholicism not least of all because of
Catholicism's architectural heritage as
deliberately caution and strongly he'll
said there's there's a a very
problematic attempting Worple to
distinguish between the aesthetics of
catholicism in its its theological
legacy so it's it's the disgust is never
as object in relation to catholicism you
know what i mean at least it's the
architectural and aesthetic level
obsessed but I think you can't just see
also and again that would serve the
mysterious husband you know the the
mistresses in Paris going on in
eighteenth-century England where the
French of the enemy well and we read the
prologue in the epilogue that Walpole
wrote for his own play and the bit that
I read you wrote imagining Kitty Clive
doing it and then takes that job at
Methodist as well so I said of course I
have to take this yeah but I think that
there again we're coming back to the
religious context and we can't
understand that even if
we had to lay some of that on the
cutting room floor to get this and I
just stood arms and Cindy Cindy Roman -
and we put to put our heads together and
thought about people who have a
connection to the Lewis Walpole library
and people who might be available and
around and volts were so generous with
their time Joe rode to help me find this
fantastic young man Carlos is here and
he'll there - had to go so we we wove it
together and we did truly just get
together for the first time on Monday
night I think it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
atomizer is so dependent on the countess
impersonal and so when the countess
starts to break down I think there seems
to be a lot of inconsistency analyze is
she excited about getting married -
she's not gonna get married is she does
she want to become another does she like
this mysterious young man that she's met
it's unclear but I think that ultimately
comes down to that she wants to please
the countess and so whatever the
countess is telling her including doom
yourself by being married again to
mention that conscious lovers again you
know think of Indiana it's always the
the root of the orphan who is revealed
to have either the key to happiness or
the key to ruin in the in the play I
think I think we want to release you to
the to the reception and the wine and
the cheese and the and congratulating
the actors as you as you would encounter
them in the room but thank you very much
for her stay
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]